with us today is kyle simani to talk
about all things crypto welcome to the
program kyle jason pleasure to be on the
show long time fan
thank you oh that's that's very kind of
you um i know that a number of my
besties uh were early supporters of uh
multi coin capital my friend vinnie
lingam my guest is one of your partners
he introduced you guys to the famous
bill lee that nobody knows uh who's
actually the greatest investor angel
investor of all time the true goat but
since he's underground i get to claim
that uh title and then my friend david
sachs of course from craft we're anchor
lps in your fund so tell us about what
was multi what is multicoin tell us
about that first fund and the thesis for
how you're investing uh sure so while
doing capital is an investment firm uh
based in austin texas we have 15
employees
a few billion and assets across various
funds
we have two primary fund structures we
manage a hedge fund and adventure fund
craft is uh invest in both of those
vehicles and we invest in crypto things
we invest predominantly in tokens we do
invest in equity from time to time but
are definitely token focused investors
um we have kind of three mega theses
that we've outlined on our website and
those have been there for a few years
and continue to guide our investments
and i expect these will
theses will continue to compound
indefinitely
those three theses are open finance
which is kind of a superset of defy
the three and the opportunity for
non-sovereign money i think out of
everything we we have done falls into
one of those three buckets although i'll
i'll i will admit web 3 is a little bit
broad um and a little all-encompassing
um
today
between our hedge fund on a venture fund
uh although the the
legal structures are mechanically
different
um they're the same investment team
manages both of those um and it's the
same core theses across them and in fact
there's a lot of name overlap as well
between them our venture funds are
typically higher risk higher reward more
concentration in newer names our hedge
fund is a larger later stage entity um
then holds but ends up holding a lot of
the same names because we like to hold
stuff that we like and we like to hold
as much of it as we can
um
and that's kind of how we do things and
uh part of the idea is that you will run
one of the nodes on these new networks
so
you get to understand it so you're
actually
participating in
the formation in some way of these new
projects i guess is what we call them
today not companies they're projects
correct people use the term project tune
protocol um
collective dow i mean there's there's a
lot of weird names for these things um
running nodes is part of of
you know being involved in these systems
but i would argue it's actually some
somewhat of a commodity um
we don't run nodes in-house ourselves we
work with probably 15 different firms
externally to do various node
operational things
um then we work with 15 and not one
because we want to be decentralized and
help these networks stay physically
and organizationally decentralized
um i think the the real value add we
bring when we work with portfolio
companies or portfolio protocols
whatever you'd like to call projects yep
projects projects protocols and
platforms
i guess the three ps i'm trying to
understand this myself but i get it
um
but i mean it comes from i say stuff
that looks more like what vcs do so
helping with recruiting helping with
messaging helping uh with strategy
um
and then i think a couple of things that
are particularly unique to crypto
um the most notable of which i would
highlight is what i'll call engaging in
crypto capital markets
um
capital markets and equities both public
and private um
they evolve over time but they're
relatively static at any moment in time
um
and because they're quite regulated um
it's hard for them to change
probably the for example the largest
change that's happened over the last
decade has been the length of time in
which private companies stay private um
and in crypto you have kind of the exact
opposite phenomenon that's happened um
which is these things go public you know
at one month or maybe like six months
old um
and
and that's a very different
set of things that that happens in the
life of of building something of value
um it changes how you have to think
about messaging and and uh to
constituents groups so customers versus
users versus speculators um those are
different constituencies and like it's
not always obvious um
how to think about balancing those
different stakeholder groups um in
particular
there's even the venues in which people
trade these assets are obviously
different these are not trading on the
new york stock exchange or the nasdaq
um
and how do you you know uh
again like even messaging right you
don't have quarterly reports or ten cues
or any of these things
so figuring out the right kind of
communication and uh cadence and format
and strategy um thinking about exchanges
thinking about countries
thinking about languages like this is
just a very different set of problems um
right even most american publicly traded
companies i would venture to guess have
extremely few chinese retail investors
as owners of their their their equity um
in crypto that's probably not true
and so
um you know young
uh
groups of people working on these
interesting hard problems
have to
deal with you know these kinds of things
and it's very non-intuitive how to go
about thinking about messaging and
communicating and coordinating in this
new capital market
um
folks like us you know who've done this
30 40 50 times um have seen what works
and what doesn't work and can help those
teams kind of figure out the right
capital markets engagement strategy um i
think that's a one of the things we do
that's that's particularly unique and it
takes years of doing this to kind of
figure out how to do it 30 or 40 times
you've met a founding
founding members of a project a company
a team a crypto project and then been
the first investor or amongst the first
investors who buy those tokens in the
initial token sale is that correct
correct how do you find those companies
uh are they all hanging on telegram or
is it you know uh on discord servers or
is it just in the just a
crypto community writ large
yeah i mean that's the way we source
deals and get deals done is is pretty
similar to how most vcs do it so we have
networks obviously in the crypto
community other investors other
entrepreneurs people are sending us
stuff all the time uh we know a lot of
people directly obviously and they just
called news message us and we chat i
love cold emails my twitter dms are open
for better or for worse
um so stuff comes in that way um you
know there's hackathons which you know
again we attend and are kind of involved
with in various forms so the actual
mechanics of sourcing are pretty pretty
standard um
in terms of getting deals done i would
also say it's pretty standard the only
difference really between i'd say deals
we do and um traditional equity deals is
these token provisions that are added to
them um the token provisions are
unfortunately not as standardized as i
would i would like
um and that's just the reality of teams
being in different countries
um llc's versus c corps
some warrants and other things
there's a lot less standardization there
than um
so with a project like solana how did
you find them and then how did that
initial token offering go down how much
did you put in how many tokens were
released when did all that happen tell
us the story of solana
yeah so
um i actually don't remember who
introduced us to anatoly vinnie
vinnie may have introduced us so
uh met with anatoly at some point in
april of 2018 while i was in sf for some
other reason
um i recall a few things about that
first meeting um one the title slide
the subtitle of the title slide said
nasdaq for blockchain
and i remember thinking this is very
corny and like overplayed but like okay
you're making a very pointed
argument or claim
um
and then two anatoly um
had a very different background than all
the other layer one founders i had
spoken to what does layer one mean to
for people who are neophytes
yeah so i mean bitcoin is a layer one
ethereum is a layer one um
polka dot was kind of a layer one uh
phantom bin and smart chain probably
layer one what what is it sorry a layer
one block chain so these are this is at
the actual physical network of nodes
that are maintaining a database that can
run smart contracts of some form got it
so when people launch a project they can
launch on a layer one platform and
that's where their tokens reside and
they don't have to build the
infrastructure over again correct yes
committing to security and compliance is
vital for startup growth and proof of
security has never been more important
as you scale you might start to receive
more sock to request from customers of
course and that's where drada comes in
trada is a compliance automation
platform used by some of the world's
leading csos cisos you may have heard of
it chief information security officers a
lot of early state startups don't have a
cso despite the obvious importance of
security and compliance with drata you
can easily meet requirements support
enterprise deal flow and track
compliance strata helps customers
prepare for and clear sock 2 and other
audits go from zero to audit ready in a
matter of weeks take it from philip
martin chief security officer at
coinbase he called drata solution well
ahead of other market players and said
drada provides users with the most
advanced automation available so here's
your cta check out drata's five-star
reviews on g2 and see why companies like
clearco and smartrecruiter work with
drata for their compliance needs twist
listeners can get 15 percent off and
waived implementation fees at drata.com
twist d-r-a-t-a dot com list